bonjour à vous jean marc sylvestre merci
d'être en direct avec nous alors
globalement est ce que les annonces
faites par emmanuel macron correspondent
à ce qu'on attendait bah écoutez je
crois que le président a changé de ton
en tous les cas il apparu effectivement
beaucoup plus précis plus convaincu
qu'auparavant avec un agenda calendrier
avec des mesures il a commencé un peu
repris la main sur ce que je faisais
avant son premier ministre ou le
ministre de l'économie premier toit vous
l'avez dit les mesures d'allégement
correspondent en gros à ce qu'on
attendait les commerces vont donc
pouvoir rouvrir c'était justice la
révolte grogne est bon les théâtres les
cinémas il faudra encore attendre la
proche de noël pour pouvoir travailler
des lieux de culte pour ouvrir ce la vie
les restaurateurs sont un peu les grands
perdants de cette opération les
directeurs de stations de ski aussi vont
être en colère parce qu'ils ont raté le
début de leur leur saison ils seront
fermés jusqu'au 15 janvier au moins
l'exécutif se fonde la sur des études
qui montrent que les restaurants et une
station de ski étaient et sont toujours
des foyers de contamination et ça un peu
dans le monde entier j'imagine que le
gouvernement n'a pas fait ça l'unim pour
embêter ces professionnels il a fait ça
parce que ça fait correspondre à des
critères relatifs mention signifie qu'on
va maintenant maintenir des restrictions
de circulation on était finalement un
peu emprisonné dans tout cela il ya une
espèce de liberté provisoire qui va ce
qui va s'installer trois heures de
promenade à 20 km on va instituer quand
même le couvre-feu amateurs sauf vous le
disiez encore pour les soirs de noël et
du nouvel an à condition de faire des
réunions de famille assez étroite avec
grande réunion de famille recomposée
je crois qu'il va falloir un peu oublié
puis le deuxième point c'est qu'on a
pour la première fois un agenda précis
un calendrier à cap aussi qui permet à
tout le monde d'avoir le sentiment qu'on
va pouvoir atteindre le but du tunnel
dans cette crise sanitaire et en sortir
de temps et c'est le troisième point
qu'ils annoncent une campagne de
vaccination qui pourraient commencer fin
décembre on espère que les choses là
seront un peu mieux organisées
peut être que pour les masques et les
tests on peut être nue dans
amusé parce que si l'europe finalement
qui a pris la l'initiative de tout cela
enfin on a là un schéma qui est quand
même à peu près cohérent alors quel va
être l'impact économique de ces mesures
bah écoutez il faut pas se cacher la
vérité emmanuel macron a profité du
recul de l'épidémie pour atteindre deux
objectifs qui sont réduits et le premier
objectif c'est un objectif politique
parce que le pays était à bout le coach
croit que les gens ne supportaient plus
se confirme il y avait une déprime une
chape de plomb qui étaient installés sur
le pays c'était trop compliqué et trop
floue c'était trop contradictoires et on
sentait bien que la cocotte-minute
pouvait exploser donc il va retirer le
bouchon
ça peut ça peut tenir et mais il y avait
aussi urgemment un objectif économique
omise de l'économie bruno le maire avait
d'ailleurs tiré la sonnette d'alarmé à
plusieurs reprises au cours des jours
derniers il fallait laisser respirer
pays alors ce confinement va coûter sans
doute moins cher que le premier mais au
total le pays va quand même perdre cette
année pratiquement plus de 12% depuis
certains parlent même de 13 ou 14% de
richesse avec des secteurs qui sont
complètement en ruines être un
l'hôtellerie l'aéronautique les
restaurants on sait pas dans quel état
ils vont s'en sortir mais ça va pas être
brillants les industries culturelles
c'est un désastre
alors l'année 21 va être très compliqué
aussi parce qu'il y aura des faillites
en chine il va y avoir des dérèglements
tu as eu des règlements des dépôts de
bilan d'opportunités il va falloir
assumer des mutations digital transition
écologique mais aussi
réindustrialisation alors derrière cette
crise économique et sociale
on sent bien que va se profiler une
crise financière une crise de la dette
parce qu'il va falloir financer tout ça
il va falloir payer cette dette que nous
avons contracté la crise beaucoup plus
d'un milliard par jour
il fallait absolument freiner ce
mouvement alors une question et pas des
moindres à jean marx fs comment on va
rembourser tout cela oui alors écoutez
la question est taboue vous l'avez
remarqué il ya pas eu un mot sur le
financement le quoi qu'il en coûte
emmanuel macron sans les féliciter
évidemment parce que ça a quand même
rendu beaucoup de services à la société
et à l'économie mais il va falloir quand
même maintenant changer de paradigme et
on espère que la croissance sera au
rendez vous et la croissance permettrait
de revenir à l'équilibré mais il faudra
quand même sept ou dix ans on espère que
la banque centrale européenne reprendra
cette dette
mais pour l'instant elle n'a pas le
droit de le faire il faut l'accord de
tous les européens on a déjà du mal à
s'accorder sur des sur des emprunts qui
seraient mutualisés
ça reviendrait évidemment à faire de la
planche à billets et pour l'instant
c'est interdit par les traités
la seule question que tout le monde se
pose c'est évidemment celle du vaccin et
là tout le monde est assez optimiste et
quand on est optimiste et bien on trouve
de l'argent à emprunter facilement vous
avez bien vu la bourse les marchés
financiers sont quand même dans une dans
un climat qui est bien meilleur qu'il ya
encore une dizaine de jours on emprunte
à facilement quand on est en train
justement on emprunte acquirent à
écouter c'est là encore c'est la
question qu'on se compose pas mais on
emprunte à des gens qui ont de l'argent
et il ya beaucoup d'argent notamment les
épargnants alors si si ils n'apportent
pas leur épargne aux contributions de
l'état le risque c'est qu'on invente des
impôts nouveaux mots sauf que les impôts
il y en a déjà beaucoup non on emprunte
aussi un certain nombre de pays parce
qu'il ya des pays qui ont des surplus
je pense aux pays pétroliers puis je
pense surtout à la chine la chine s'est
réveillé la chine a repris de la
croissance la chine a des excédents et
la chine peut se proposer de nous prêter
de l'argent
ce qu'elle a déjà commencé à le faire je
dirais quand même un retour à un retour
et une revanche de l'histoire assez
cocasse
merci beaucoup à vous jean marc
sylvestre je rappelle que vous êtes un
éditorialiste économique